hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down
the latest developments in the boku no
hero story
and this new chapter was absolutely
incredible
we finally met the last two users
of one for all the second and third user
we finally got to see them face to face
and
it is strongly implied that they may
have started out as villains
who worked for all for one we also got
some hints
about what their quirks might have been
and we even had some powerful social
commentary
in this chapter so let's get into it if
you enjoy our boku no hero videos and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second and it's a completely free way to
support
the channel and of course if you're new
to anime pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but it's the
only way to make sure that youtube will
actually
show you our videos finally this video
will of course contain boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with what looks like a group
of ordinary citizens who decided to take
up arms and attack
a large woman this woman has a mutant
type quirk that makes her extremely tall
and she also has an animal-esque
appearance and so it is her appearance
alone that made this
citizen militia of sorts think that she
was a villain
they call her a monster and attack her
mercilessly by the way i am not sure
which animal her appearance is based on
my guess is either fox girl or like a
doe which is a female deer
but i'm sure that the furry connoisseurs
and the comments will be more qualified
to make that determination than i am of
course the important thing to note here
is this this woman is no villain
she is just a regular scared citizen who
was trying to evacuate from a dangerous
area this poor furry lady is terrified
as the militiamen launch
multiple attacks against her but
thankfully
deku shows up just in time to help deku
tells everyone to calm down
he knows that it's night time and it's
dangerous out here and tensions are high
but this lady is not their enemy the
militiamen decide to back off
but as they depart they say that if this
lady is really innocent then she should
stop
acting so suspicious but here's the
thing
she wasn't acting suspicious the
militiamen were just paranoid and they
judged this woman based on her
appearance
alone and of course her appearance is
not something that she can change
just looking like that in itself is not
suspicious
she was just trying to evacuate from
this area
so she ended up on the streets alone at
night and so it was her size and her
appearance that scared
these militia people and since they were
already on edge because of all the
villain activity in the area
they decided to attack her i think we
have some powerful social commentary
here
about not judging people based on their
appearance
and about not overreacting in stressful
situations
i mean yeah it sucks that the villains
are out there causing chaos and that
this is putting everyone on edge
but the moment you attack an innocent
person out of fear and ignorance
you yourself become the villain deku
then has a very wholesome moment with
the furry lady
in which he floats up and gives her an
umbrella and he tells her that everyone
is scared and that is why stuff like
this is happening when she asks deku
whether things will ever return to
normal again
he tells her that they will as always
deku is being hopeful and optimistic
and he is attempting to help others feel
more hopeful and optimistic as well
oh and then almight shows up in what
looks like the freaking batmobile
like seriously the batman references are
everywhere and almight then proceeds to
escort the furry lady to the evacuation
center as deku continues patrolling the
streets
as a vigilante but before deku leaves
all might make sure to give him his
lunch
and he tells him to eat it quickly
before it gets cold
man all might is literally alfred
and deku's dad at the same time and
personally i think that's
freaking adorable not gonna lie and yes
i know that deku technically has a real
dad out
there somewhere allegedly but let's face
it all might
is basically deku's dad at this point
some time later
as deku looks down on the city from a
rooftop the vestige of daigo robondro
mentions just how much society has
regressed into the past
it's like japan turned the clock back to
the time when all for one was in his
prime and controlling the entire country
from the shadows
what's more the good guys haven't made
any real progress
in terms of tracking down shigaraki all
for one and the other major villains
this is because even when they are able
to track down some of the prison skps
like muscular
the skps all end up being completely
clueless about all for one's whereabouts
it seems that these villains were broken
out of prison for the sole purpose of
wreaking havoc
and keeping the heroes busy so they
don't really have any important
information about the final bosses
shigaraki and all for one
and worse yet now that shigaraki has the
all for one quirk
no one will be able to stop him if he
can fully recover his strength
and perfect his new form if deku and one
for all cannot put a stop to all of this
chaos right now
then this terrible situation is going to
continue
and next time someone innocent like that
furry lady might actually be killed
because someone gets paranoid and
mistakes her for a villain
the more the good guys wait to put a
stop to this chaos
the more innocent people are going to
suffer deku
desperately wants to make things right
as soon as possible
and so he appeals to all the vestiges to
work together with him
and this includes the two most
mysterious vestiges
the second and third users the guys who
up to this point had refused to even
show their faces to deku
let alone cooperate with him in any
meaningful way we then
finally get a flashback to what happened
during deku's meeting with the vestiges
prior to the moment that he woke up from
his coma or rather we get a continuation
of that important conversation
interestingly
the first one for all user calls the
second and third users his heroes
and he then begs them to turn around and
help
deku after some prodding from the other
vestiges
the second and third user finally turn
around and
show their faces the third user
the one with the long hair says that the
two of them are from the harshest era of
history
back when all41 was at his very peak and
was ready to dominate
the entire world back in those days some
people who were being dominated by all
for one didn't even necessarily realize
that they were being dominated at all
back when they were still alive the
second and third user worked
together with the first user and we then
learned that the first user's name
appears to be yoichi so we appear to
finally have the full name
of the first user one for all yoichi
shigaraki
anyway in the process of trying to stop
all for one from assuming full control
of japan
the first three users had to sacrifice
many lives too many lives to count the
second user the one who looks like an
older bakugo with a scar on his face
says that at the end of every battle
there is either victory
or defeat so because these guys have
experienced
such a harsh reality and because they
know how much sacrifice is required to
come out on top in any deadly conflict
they seem to actually have doubts about
deku
to them deku appears to be just a
bright-eyed idealistic brat who thinks
he could save everyone
including his own arch nemesis this
speaks directly to what i've been saying
for several weeks now
and to what gran torino tried to tell
deku shigaraki might be
beyond saving and trying to save him
instead of taking him out
may prove to be extremely dangerous and
extremely
costly yoichi the first user then says
yes this idea of saving shigaraki is
certainly delusional
but it's also similar to the time when a
certain pair
the second and third user saved their
own nemesis we then see that after all
for one had imprisoned his brother
it was actually the second and third
users who rescued him and extended a
helping hand
to him woah the fact that the first user
described
this as the other two helping their
nemesis
implies that they were villains unless
i'm missing something
this implies that the second and third
user were actually working with
all for one but at some point they had a
change of heart and they decided to turn
against all for one and save the first
one for all user so earlier on when the
third user mentioned
all for one dominating people without
them even realizing that they were being
dominated
he might have been talking about himself
and the second user
perhaps they were being manipulated by
all for one and while this was happening
they actually saw the first one for all
user
as their nemesis but at some point they
learned the truth and they turned
against
all for one and if it wasn't for them if
they hadn't released the first user and
then allowed him to pass
one for all on to them one for all never
would have become
what it is today and what it is today is
the single most effective weapon
against all for one on the final page of
the chapter
we see all of the vestiges standing
united behind
deku the vestiges say that we are now
going
full speed ahead it kind of looks like
the second user is the one saying this
but i'm not sure if it's him or if it's
still banjo talking
either way deck replies yes sir and that
is how this
awesome chapter ends wow i thought that
this chapter was
excellent we got the face reveal for the
second
and third user we learned that they
apparently used to be villains before
they betrayed over one and teamed up
with the first
one for all user we learned the first
one for all users full name
and we saw some pretty amazing social
commentary
complete with that wholesome umbrella
moment and all might showing up in the
freaking batmobile
absolutely awesome chapter and probably
one of my favorites in boku no hero
definitely let me know what you guys
thought of the chapter and do you think
the deku already has the last two quirks
at this point can he already use them or
is he
yet to unlock them also what are these
quirks
going to be will one of them be a speed
based quirk
so that whole full speed ahead was like
a hint and will the other one be some
sort of long range blasting quirk
since in the flashback the second user
looked like he blasted the door
open in order to rescue the first user
of one for all
honestly a speed quirk and a long range
quirk would be incredibly useful for
deku
and those two quirks just might be the
two missing pieces that deku needs
in order to be able to take on a
perfected shigaraki
the first part of this chapter really
made it clear that society as a whole
has crumbled and even regular citizens
are losing their minds
amid all the panic and chaos i mean this
is really getting dangerous now and not
just because of the villains
regular citizens are turning on each
other
and deco and the heroes really need to
do something before it's too
late the time crunch is on and i can't
wait to see what happens
next if you guys enjoyed this video and
you want to see more boku no your
content right here on the channel
please leave that like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you are new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the best way to make
sure that you won't miss a bunch of
videos in the future is to subscribe
hit that notification bell and then
select the option that says
all otherwise youtube might bury our
videos
and you could easily miss a whole bunch
of them you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at anime uproar a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and avi these guys are absolute mad lads
and disciples of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata pate heffa algertol dr
cortman the toasted chi
bang emperor otaku spidey life tinel
tungsten tarquez big buddhist
and you know finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
rothlin de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joy and
garcia ted no ted
iceparky65 jessica lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see us peace cowboys
[Music]
you